ich denke die muss auch meine meinung
vertreten können auch wenn es andere
nicht gefällt und ich sage einmal gilt
man in deutschland schon als rechts nur
weil man regelmäßig rechte dinge sagt
[Musik]
hier trifft sich heute eine kleine
aufrechte gruppe sie sind die letzte
bastion gegen den grassierenden tugend
waren und die ständigen denkverbote des
gutmenschen terrors und sie sind
garantiert nicht rechts die heute show
lässt die afg heute aus reden denn wir
haben den mut zur wahrheit heute morgen
wurde in den nachrichten ja wurden dem
politischen aschermittwoch aufgeführt
aber die afg wurde gar nicht erwähnt
aber jetzt wir sind doch live drauf
jetzt wir sind jetzt live im zdf de
wurde gerne schauen sie noch sagen jetzt
gehen und wenn sie samt jetzt ist ja
mittwoch wir sind live auf sendung geht
jaja so ich habe sie am mittag mal was
wollen sie denn sagen sagen wir damit
sagen dass der afg von den staatssender
nicht erwähnt wird und an tisch gehalten
ihre gefallenen gelassen wird
zum beispiel die hypo afrika patenkind
dann ist die mutter um ihr kind hierher
gekommen so ist es in ordnung
mittlerweile wohnt account sippschaft
schaut das meine ich und die ganze
sippschaft schaut wollen sie eigentlich
wirklich ins eben parlament ja wirklich
sagen aber ihnen ist schon bewusst aus
da überwiegend ausländer sitzen
das heißt aus den sitzen die sitzen ja
fast überall schon waren sie nicht den
eindruck dass die staatsmedien die alb
die hassen
das müssen sie beurteilen ich hab den
eindruck nicht ach so ja wir hassen sie
sie sind ja ein verfechter der familie
aber was ist wenn eine familie jetzt
sehr sehr dumme kinder hat sollte man
die ausweisen ausweislich kinder du
weißt nicht nach münchen games prozent
und aus dem gottes willen nein nein
natürlich nicht und wenn die nicht nur
sehr sehr dumm sind die kinder sondern
auch sehr sehr homosexuellen berichten
wir die medien deshalb so negativ über
die afg weil wir neidisch auf ihren
intellekt sind das glaube ich nicht ich
glaube eher dass da eine
voreingenommenheit herrscht weil die
meisten die da berichten sich nicht
wirklich mit der afg auseinandersetzen
so wie ich habe mich jetzt auch gar
nicht vorbereitet tatsächlich wahlsieg
und schnee hat nicht gar nichts bedeutet
haben sie es genau zugehört nähe auch
nicht noch ein kleines stück genau hier
in die ecke super ich wollte nur mal
gucken ob man sie in die rechte ecke
drängen kann
und das tut was macht akademiker
eigentlich zu den besseren menschen und
warum will der pöbel dass da draußen
einfach nicht kapieren die akademiker
sind keine besseren menschen und pöbel
draußen gibt es nicht das ist eine
erfindung des des zdf also ich würde
mich tatsächlich schon als pöbel
bezeichnen tatsächlich können auch wenn
es andere nicht gefällt und ich sage
einmal gilt man in deutschland schon als
rechts wobei man regelmäßig rechte dinge
sagt rechts ist nicht gleich rechts hat
recht
aber bei der ard meinungsfreiheit groß
geschrieben oder richtig ich kann jeder
sagen was er will
im großen ganzen
[Musik]
ja wahrscheinlich ein vertreter dieser
linken staatsmedien kuschelstimmung
verwandelt
ich hoffe ja bringt wirklich die guten
ausschnitt der auf ja hier in dem
beitrag er worauf sie sich verlassen
können
so aufnahme hallo
dies ist die automatische and cut von
oliver welke und der heute show
leider ist das video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres video
anschauen vielen dank so müsse jetzt für
immer reich